Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 18th,
2013.
How the hell are you?
How's it going?
I'm going to try to fuck an energy my way through the energy.
We to find a Samsung.
A new,
can I fuck up?
Ooh,
I'm wiped out.
Why you wiped out pill?
You,
all you do is jump around like a fucking monkey on stage.
That's what you do for your money,
for your legal tech.
Uh,
well,
you know what?
I've been doing it in every fucking state,
the Goddamn Union this year and I'm wiped out.
I'm officially wipe the fuck out.
I had a 6:20 AM flight out of Wichita,
Kansas.
Hey,
why do we have ourselves bar murder down their last name and,
uh,
landed here at seven 38 and I'm one of those little ass fucking planes because
nobody goes to Wichita.
Not Directly.
Anyways,
so I was on a little last plane.
We landed in a little last plane and you know what happens?
A little less planes.
They don't get to pull up to the gate.
Aw,
you're too small.
You're going to hurt yourself little last plane.
So we're sitting out there on the fucking champ,
right?
It's an old school playing.
They tried to paint it like a new United plane,
but they still had the you that was from um,
you know,
like the 70s was a fucking old ass plane.
Okay.
I don't know if they took it over to gas monkey garage and they put a new
fucking engine in it.
I don't know what,
but we made it,
but it was one of those deals where they open the door and the stairs are part
of the fucking door.
We walk out of that and then we get on the Goddamn plane,
a plane,
a bus bus to the fucking airport.
The hub within the bags came up.
Oh Shit.
So I am,
uh,
but you know something.
I completed the red state tour.
All right?
It was supposed to be a nice,
wonderful summer jaunt through the red states of this country,
through some of them.
By the way,
there's a lot of people giving me shit.
Go in Nebraska.
Nebraska's a red state too.
I was a red states of fucking red state.
You know what?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Okay.
I got something for you.
I get some for you can't out there who keep giving me shit?
Why don't you fucking come to my,
what do you got against my fucking state?
What do you got against coming to one of my,
I've been in over 50 cities,
50 goddamn cities.
I don't know what else I'm supposed to do to try to find you fuckers.
All right,
you want to hear,
want to hear a quick little rundown?
Do you want to know what all these cities have in common?
Honolulu,
Seattle,
Boise,
Bozeman,
San Francisco,
San Jose.
Los Angles is Burbank,
Coachella,
Palm Springs,
Napa Valley.
Santa Wine Has Phoenix,
Las Vegas,
boulder,
Colorado Springs,
deadwood,
El Paso,
San Antonio,
Austin,
Dallas,
Minneapolis,
Madison,
Milwaukee,
grand rapids,
royal oak,
Chicago,
Kansas City,
St Louis,
Indianapolis,
Cincinnati,
Cleveland,
Buffalo,
Pittsburgh,
Huntsville,
Morgan town,
Philadelphia,
Atlantic City,
red bank,
New York City,
Montville,
Newport,
Hyannis,
Boston,
Hampton beach,
watching JCA,
Charleston,
Atlanta,
Athens,
Birmingham,
Tallahassee,
Tampa,
and Miami.
Okay.
It tells some fucker Wichita.
You know what they all have in common?
I fucking dance like a monkey there for an hour.
So if I didn't it just stay to your city.
I don't know what the fuck else I got to do.
Um,
um,
wiped out as they say in Oklahoma,
clapped that was watching their local,
um,
or that the shopping network,
you know those things where like the husband's out working or something in the
wife gets like addicted and just has to buy those dire mills or whatever.
And they had this cross and she goes,
now look at this.
This is genuine white gold.
It's kept going white.
All right.
Quiet gold.
Quiet only.
Hey,
guess where the racisms from whites only dope.
That's Boston,
right?
Watch only.
That's Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
At least that's where I watched it.
And then lastly,
why it's only,
okay,
that's a gay guy at a laundromat.
Sorry.
It's a bad job.
Fuck you up.
Tired.
Don't get,
don't get the whites best in with the colors.
Um,
anyways,
whatever.
This podcast is going to suck,
but maybe it's going to be enjoyable because of how much it sucks.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know what the fuck I'm going to talk about this week.
Let's,
let's get,
let's get right into a little bit of a,
my tour.
I'll just call it 15 audible's.
As I was saying that,
dragging that sentence out,
let's get into a little,
by the way,
you know,
right now and run,
he's supposed to be doing this podcast.
I'm supposed to be talking to somebody from Reykjavik and I gotta tell you
Iceland.
Well,
the first guy had water damage.
I called them up.
It sounded like it just happened.
So we're rescheduling that one.
And then the other dude at 10 30,
I don't know what happened,
man.
I'm sitting here on the other side of the world,
eagerly awaiting your phone call.
And what do I get?
I get nothing.
You know what somebody told me when I go over to that beautiful country of
Iceland,
you know,
that country that stood up to the bankers,
that country that I can't wait to go see somebody said it smells like sulfur
because of that.
Uh,
that volcanic eruption there,
volcanic,
the volcano eruption.
Um,
remember that one that blocked all the flights to and from Europe a few years
ago.
It still smells like sulfur over there.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I think that's kind of fucking cool to be that close to a live volcano.
Um,
I can't fucking,
that's one of the ones I'm really looking forward to that because,
uh,
on that trip over there,
I,
that's the country I haven't been to yet,
so I don't give a fuck what it smells like.
I heard the women are beautiful.
Ah,
they stuck up to the banks and they fucking live right next to a volcano.
They don't give a shit.
So thumbs up to Iceland.
I can't wait to go and I think I'm actually going to get to see the northern
lights,
you know,
stand there with a little tear in my eye,
wondering why humanity can't get along.
Um,
so anyways,
I,
I did,
uh,
the rest of the red state tours,
dates and um,
you know,
I know it was crazy as far as like,
it didn't come off the way I've thought it was going on,
but I honored every fucking date and I added San Antonio.
All right.
We made them happen.
El Paso took three times to get to three trips.
One time I canceled cause I'm a little twinkle toes doing my acting work.
The next time it got rained out.
And then finally we made it happen and I got some angry emails,
but in the end we made it happen.
So anyway,
so I go to deadwood,
South Dakota in the black hills,
the western part of South Dakota.
And uh,
I had a fucking awesome time.
Highly recommended.
I went and I actually saw a Mt.
Rushmore,
scratch that off the bucket list.
Um,
and I highly recommend that you go during the winter months because I could just
tell it would be fucking packed with a bunch of God damn breeders with their
fucking gene cutoff shorts.
As I was walking up all the stairs and nobody was on you that nobody was on.
I could just,
I said to the guy who brought us over there,
I was like,
dude,
this place is packed in the summertime.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
man,
it's awful.
It's awful.
So go there in the winter,
nice,
crisp air,
whatever the fall,
whatever fuck season we're in right now.
That's the time to go.
Toughen up.
You fucking kids.
Pull them out of school and bring him there.
All right.
Start up the Winnebago once over the winter or in the fall by that.
I can get the thing up there.
I'm telling you,
it's great.
We did the whole God damn thing and like 20 minutes.
You know what's great as you come up the hill.
I'm literally miming this with my hand,
like driving my head towards my face in case I forget what it's like to drive up
a hill.
As you're driving up a hill,
you come up all the way up the mountain there,
right?
Or The hills I guess.
And,
uh,
all you see,
just look out and I swear to God,
you can see all the way to Wyoming and you're like,
what the fuck?
Where is it?
And then you just come around a turn in the way they do it is so fucking cool.
They show you what the four presidents are looking at and then you turn around
and you're like,
holy fuck.
There it is like a God damn horror movie.
You know,
you think the guys behind the curtain and he's not there and you're like,
oh good.
And yet,
yeah,
you relax.
You let out that exhale,
he turned around La Jesus Christ for dead presidents.
You know,
if you know for the life of me,
I always wondered why they picked those four.
Not even those four.
Why Teddy Roosevelt?
You know,
I understood malarian curly,
but I didn't get SCHEMPP.
Why the fuck is he up there?
You know,
I didn't understand it was another good reference.
Okay.
David Lee Roth,
Sammy Hagar,
and then that dude from that,
that band,
if you doll lie,
what we do here?
Get the fuck out.
Shut up.
Whoa,
whoa.
Oh my God.
I never want to drag somebody down the fucking stairs by their ponytails.
As much as when that fucking Sean came on.
Um,
anyways,
Teddy Roosevelt.
So I was,
I asked the guy there,
why did they,
why Teddy?
I don't see the fucking connection here.
It's like a bad standup tour.
What do you get?
Three styles that Mesh and then just one guy has got,
I dunno,
a fucking Ukulele and I guess they were all responsible for the expansion
expansionism of this country,
George Washington,
because he helped us with our conspiracy theory,
that theory or conspiracy to fucking leave the God damn,
uh,
English empire.
All right.
Which started,
it does not really expanding that sort of separating,
but who the fuck am I?
Uh,
Thomas Jefferson,
Louisiana purchase.
Okay.
Oh my God,
I'm gonna forget who else was there.
Oh,
Abe.
Abe Lincoln.
Abraham a tray as his friends call him.
Uh,
cause he held the union together.
Um,
and then Teddy Roosevelt,
because he,
uh,
was brutally racist.
It was able to,
uh,
kick all the Mexicans out of the western part of this country.
You know,
that's a really weird part.
I gotta tell you this really weird part of the country.
Uh,
South Dakota.
Absolutely fucking beautiful,
but it's kind of like,
I feel like what Germany would look like if the Germans won the way history is
told.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
that is,
you're basically on a holocaust ground out there,
but because you know,
the fucking evil doers one,
just the way it's,
you know,
you can go visit Custer's last stand and they have like,
grave sites for all these fucking mass murdering psychopath.
Okay.
But you know,
they won.
So it's all like done.
Yeah.
So like basically if Hitler and those fucking maniacs one,
there would be a mount Rushmore in Germany and it would be Hitler.
It'd be a,
who is that guy?
Heimlich claim Miller,
whatever the fuck his name is.
Basically his Scottie Pippen.
Right.
And they'd have a couple other,
all his fucking Evil Nazi dudes,
I dunno where they would be facing,
but whatever.
That doesn't mean you shouldn't go out there.
It's absolutely fucking beautiful.
And I had a great time performing at the casino.
I met some real live cowboys,
real life cowboys,
got invited to go back to a ranch.
Next time I'm out there for some quick draw shooting with fucking wax bullets.
What'd you do this fucking weekend?
I already asked him.
I go,
what do you mean wax?
We should like shoot him at each other.
And they're like,
laugh.
And they go,
no,
you shoot them into a target.
I go,
what happens if you get hit with one?
They got strings.
It's not that big a deal.
So in my head I just started laughing because I was like,
all right,
back in the day,
me and my knuckle head friends,
if we got wax bullets and they're not going to kill you,
we're going to put on swimming goggles,
possibly a scuba mask.
And you know,
within 20 minutes we're going to be fucking shooting at each other.
Um,
and I guess if you go there in the summertime,
you see bald eagles out there like the pigeons.
So that's another reason to come back.
What I'm saying is I'm definitely coming back to deadwood,
Ida fucking phenomenal,
phenomenal time.
And uh,
learned a little bit about him,
American history and that type of stuff.
And uh,
then the next day it had an early flight.
I flew down to Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
and uh,
had no idea what to expect.
We drove into town,
me and Lucas.
Now you see Lee,
now you don't Lucas Seely um,
his football nickname but never happened.
They called him the Orient Express,
I believe,
or the Asian invasion.
I forget what he grew up in Montana.
He's like one of three Asians out there.
So the white people didn't know any better.
Um,
so what am I saying here?
So we own a fucking Tulsa and it's like,
uh,
I don't know.
It's like a Zombie movie.
There's like nobody there.
It's windy as fucking hell.
Cause there's nothing to stop.
The God damn wind.
And I asked the guy,
I'm like,
dude,
we pull up to the hotel and it was like creepy.
It wasn't even like homeless people.
It was like nothing but driving into town,
stopping at red lights and it's green for the other way and there's no cars.
I think it was missing was like tumbleweeds.
So we pull in there and I asked the guy when I parked the car,
I'm like,
what the hell?
What the hell is everybody?
He's like,
ah,
you know,
it gets kinda dead here on the weekends.
Um,
but at night it totally picked up and it ended up being this awesome fucking
city.
And we performed at this place called,
uh,
fuck the Brady theater.
Okay.
It old Vaudeville theater that was finished in 1916 and it was one of the
coolest places I've ever performed in.
And it was just an absolutely fucking awesome crowd.
Just had a great time.
And uh,
I dunno.
And you know,
the usual shit.
Harry Houdini performed here and they just fucking haunted and all of that crap.
Can you fill me running out of gas?
Everybody.
I run out of gas,
dude,
I've traveled too much.
Just fucking,
you know,
I'm sorry.
Let's,
let's try to start to ramp up the goddamn comedy.
I can't,
nothing funny happened at Tulsa.
Just had a great fucking time and there was a guy,
uh,
the runner,
this guy ray worked at at 1960 Cadillac and the end of,
uh,
the all original,
the end of the show,
I'm driving this thing around Tulsa 1960 fucking Cadillac having a great time.
Then we went to this German bar,
which was a good time,
but I got to tell you,
there was a little bit too much wiener Schnitzel,
if you know what I mean.
I'm just trying to be a wing man for my buddy and there was nothing to talk to
their right.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
Then the next day we drove up from Tulsa to Wichita and I gotta tell you
something about the drive from Tulsa to Wichita.
I would not work.
I would not wish that on my worst fucking enemy.
It was one of the worst drives,
the absolute,
the opposite of driving through the black hills in South Dakota.
That is one that you can skip.
There was fucking nothing,
nothing,
unless you're out there looking for some classic cars and that type of shit.
Um,
I,
you know,
I swear to God,
it was like every other fucking house out there has some fucking car.
You're like,
Holy Shit,
you know,
that's a Mustang.
Look at that.
There's an old fucking Ford pickup truck.
Every guy,
it seems like every other house.
I'm exaggerating,
but there was probably like,
I still probably like 20 cars on the way up and trucks.
And then there was a whole,
you know,
I don't know,
it's one guy had like fucking 30 of the old things up there.
I just started thinking in that,
that uh,
fast and loud that they should just drive that a,
wrapped her up there and fucking somehow talk those people into selling their
cars for 40 bucks.
And then we got into Wichita.
Wichita was a little creepy.
Not going to lie to you.
A little creepy.
I missed my term.
We came to the back part of the fucking town and uh,
we went by the Rehab Clinic and uh,
really saw that drugs touch everybody.
It looked like a fucking old,
like if they did a real world reunion episode in everybody was in their 50s.
That's what it looked like.
There was the old white guy,
the old black guy and old Asian guy and old Latino Dude,
just all fucking standing out there.
A couple of fucking haggard looking checks,
you know,
looking like retired witches.
And,
um,
we played at the Orpheum.
There were like the count Basie orchestra played Gracie,
George Burns,
grace al and Gracie Allen,
whatever they had played there.
Just fucking insane.
I'm absolutely awesome shows.
And uh,
you know,
I want to thank everybody who came out.
I'm definitely coming back.
I'm definitely going to do that run.
And next time I come back,
I'm going to add in Nebraska and uh,
I don't know what else I got to go to out there,
maybe Iowa,
but whatever.
I feel like I put my foot down out there,
left my footprint.
I got another place,
another,
a toric and do when I get old and gray or whatever.
It's all good.
Shit.
All right,
I'm just fucking me entering here.
Let's,
let's do a little advertising.
Uh,
where the fuck are we here?
And then I'm going to ramp it back up talking about that fucking bullshit
against the 40 niners and Pete Carroll's Twitter message.
All right,
I'm teasing you here.
That's a little teaser.
All right.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Let's see if I can shave a couple of strokes off my fucking bad reading.
All right.
This is how it works every week with the advertising,
whatever,
whatever mistakes I make on the first one.
That's par for the course and I just tried to see if I can go under.
All right,
here we go.
Dollar Shave Club,
everyone for a couple of bucks a month.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing quality razors right to your door.
Not only does it save you a ton of cash,
it saves you from Trojan.
You're pathetic ass down to the drugstore for a pack of blades.
I don't know about you guys,
but I always get stuck by,
and that lady pay with all our loose change from the car ashtray.
Stroke number one.
It's like she thinks exact changes that requirement.
I'm not a patient person,
but you know,
I try to be patient with old people,
but it's like,
dude,
I came in with scratch,
now I'm leaving with a bid.
Uh,
but now for dollar shave,
but now with dollar shave club to now it's all shave club for a couple bucks a
month.
Amazing quality razor blades are delivered right to your front door.
That's right.
No more wasting time and no more getting hit up for 20 bucks.
Every time you buy razors.
Everybody here is getting that dollar shave club blades and you should too.
And is a genius idea.
Try replacing your old shaving cream with Dr Carver's.
Easy shave butter from dollar shave club.com trust.
Beat your face.
We'll thank you.
Wait,
uh,
don't waste time at the drug store behind the lady paying at Penny's.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash bar or go to billboard.com and Click
on the dollar shave club banner.
Keep your stress level low and your bank account Balance High Shave time,
shave money.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Forward Slash burr.
All right,
there you go.
So two strokes is par.
Here we go.
I'm feeling good.
Failing,
failing this one.
All Right,
Hulu plus you've probably tried hulu.com now with Hulu plus,
you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Who Plus lets you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection of a claim,
movies on your television or on the go with your smart phone or tablet and it
all streams in HD for the best viewing experience possible with Hulu plus.
You could watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live
community and family guy.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals like the
authors starring Seth Meyers and mood boys starting Chris O'Dowd from
bridesmaids.
Hulu plus also offers a great selection of a claim films for only 799 a month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want wherever you want.
Right now you can try Hulu plus for free for two weeks when you go to Hulu
plus.com/bill that's a special offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get extended free trial,
the extended free trial and they know we sent you,
sent you dammit one over.
Go to Hulu plus.com/bill now or click the Hulu plus banner on the podcast page
at [inaudible] Dot Com God dammit,
I thought I had it.
All right.
What do we got left here?
All right,
let's try one more.
I've got to break par here.
One of these ones.
Can I,
can I have one flawless one?
Do you believe in me?
Here we go.
This to print vista.
Print is a small business,
but Jesus Christ.
Fuck that.
That's a Mulligan.
I'm doing it again.
Vista print.
Vista print is a small businesses best friend.
Most everything a small business needs for printing is available at Vista print.
Personalized iPhone cases available from vista print.com easily design your own
iPhone case to match your multifaceted life,
whether it's personal or business,
whether it's a family photo team,
logo,
Company logo,
your wedding,
your last vacation,
or even just personal message.
You can easily create your own iPhone case at Vista,
print.com prices as low as 1499 if you want a small business or our iPhone cases
for you and your employees with your company name and logo on it,
prospective clients will notice.
Great Way to get your company's name out there.
Give them,
give them away as company gets unlimited possibilities.
Vista print,
affordable quality marketing and printing products for small businesses.
Please talk about your experience with Vista print.
Well,
I find your,
I find your copied.
He'd be very choppy and difficult to read.
All right.
I think I said Vista print too many times.
Uh,
all iPhone cases or 25% off for my listeners.
Come on,
man.
This is a great deal here.
All right.
You have a damn bit,
Dale,
at the copy.
If you have a business right,
and you got everybody out in the field that they walk around and they got the
name right on little cell phone cover,
they walk into a bar,
they strike up a conversation with a lady.
All right,
let's go to advertising.
I believe in this product.
I just have no use for it.
I'm a one man band here.
All iPhone cases or 25% off for my listeners and get free shipping on the your
entire order.
If you spend more than 30 bucks,
just go to vistaprint.com click on the text link in the upper right hand corner.
Type in the Promo Code Bird that's vista print and click on the text link in the
upper right hand corner.
Type in the Promo Code,
burr satisfaction.
Guaranteed.
Not Happy.
They'll make it right.
No rest.
Like old school American companies.
They'll make it right.
Okay,
there you go.
Jesus Christ.
Brutal reading.
That was like a public course right there.
Bunch of fucking divots.
All right,
here we go.
Where do I start this week?
NFL Pro football.
Did Anybody Watch the 40 niners first?
The saints.
Now I am impartial.
I actually liked the saints.
I did that movie down there and I had a great fucking time and I was,
I was really getting into the saints and I think their fans are awesome and that
type of thing.
I also the 40 niners so I like both of them.
I like both coaches.
I like both quarterbacks.
I like those teams.
So I watched the game and I got to tell you the 40 niners got robbed and I'm not
blaming the saints and I don't expect St fans.
They have any empathy,
but you know God damn well if the shoe was on the other foot,
you'd be like,
what the fuck?
Okay.
Fuck the saints.
Fuck the 40 niners let's just talk football here.
What exactly was that guy supposed to do?
What he was trying to tackle?
Drew Brees.
What exactly was he?
What the fuck is he supposed to do?
Drew Brees is playing at full speed.
So on defense,
you're supposed to go,
what,
three quarters speed when the game is on the line.
It wasn't a helmet to helmet hit.
He didn't fucking,
you know,
it wasn't on an attack,
on a defenseless player or whatever the hell they call it.
He's trying to run around the outside to get to drew Brees.
He's got the fucking outside,
God Damn Lima,
whatever the fuck it is,
pushing them to the outside.
He's going by the quarterback.
He reaches out to grab him and in the process he catches him in the neck a
little bit and the guy goes down.
It's a violent fucking game.
Right?
Last year you couldn't hit him in the head.
Now you can't hit quarterbacks in the t in the head or the fucking neck.
Okay.
What are the,
what are they going to be able to do next year?
I think next year when you go to tackle the quarterback,
you ever go to put like a sheet on a bed and you do like that kind of thing and
then it goes
and lands on the bed.
What does it do bill?
It goes,
I think that's what you're going to have to do.
The 40 niners needed somebody to step up and make a fucking play and that guy
made the play.
He caused the fucking turnover and you recover the ball game.
Okay.
All right.
But because of today's game,
they took it away from him.
Yeah,
they ended up losing the game.
Okay.
That was a textbook play.
It was fucking beautiful play.
I mean,
you could sit there and watch Lawrence Taylor highlights and he has a zillion of
those.
He used to,
he used to just bull rush people,
reach over them,
grabbed the quarterback by his shirt and just drag them down to the ground.
I just,
you can't fucking do anything anymore.
And uh,
I dunno.
I don't know if it's because I've been watching football too long.
Let to me that looks like football and now they're saying it isn't.
I obviously like most of you probably saw that interview with Tony Doerr set and
I hate seeing that type of stuff.
I don't want former football players to be like that,
but Jesus Christ,
he didn't get a concussion.
Nothing.
You know,
I've,
I found really interesting was Troy Aikman thought it was a good call and how we
log was just shaking his head.
For those of you don't watch football.
Troy Aikman is a former quarterback and how he longs at former defensive tackle
or end,
I forgot what position he played.
So it's drew Brees didn't get hurt.
He didn't have a concussion.
He was fine.
He got right up Troy Aikman's going,
oh look,
you could see his lips bloody while he's playing football.
You know the fuck.
So I think the 49 has got fucked.
I don't know what the solution is.
The,
I maybe have to go back to leather helmets.
I have no idea about Jesus.
[inaudible] you gotta be able to reach out,
grab the fucking quarterback as you go down.
Yeah.
And maybe sometime he goes down a little bit violently.
I mean,
I don't fucking know.
Somebody's on my Twitter account was like laugh and go.
Like next year they're going to treat quarterbacks like kickers,
like if you even touch them,
it's an automatic unnecessary roughness.
Now that we definitely went down in a rough way,
but it's a tough game.
But he's fine if he has any sort of fucking problems at the 20 years after he
retired,
just not going to be because of that.
Yes.
I could have taken that fucking hit.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'd feel the effects for three weeks,
but I could have taken that hit and gotten up and throw a fucking goddamn duck
the next play.
I have done that and I have a stand up comedian.
If I could have taken the fucking head.
All right.
Okay.
Fuck you.
I could have the most of you could have told you could've taken it.
Jesus Christ.
I've got to hit harder than that plain fucking kill the male with the ball back
in the day or whatever you guys call the game.
Well,
that's what we call it.
Kill the male with the ball.
Murder the fucker.
Uh,
and then lastly,
the last thing I'm going to say about the fucking football this week was,
uh,
Pete Carroll's a former team that he coached USC beat 'em.
I was at Syracuse,
so fucking tired.
Beat Stanford,
which was a major upset.
And um,
okay.
Stanford had beaten USC like four years in a row,
so it was a big victory for them.
And,
uh,
so Pete Carroll tweeted,
you know,
basically it can crash.
Congratulations to USC,
which is fucking hilarious.
And then ESPN shows it.
They all blah,
blah,
blah.
And at no point did they discuss how Pete Carroll,
you know,
Pete Carol left at that team high and dry.
Oh,
maybe that's just part of the arrangement that call his football coaches have,
cause I don't begrudge the guy what he did.
He did what everybody has to do to win at a division one level as you break a
bunch of fucking rules.
But then years later they make a movie about a called blue chips with fucking
Nick Nolte.
Right.
Um,
or North Dallas flag came up with the fucking movie was called.
I don't know,
I just thought it was funny that he writes back to the school that he left high
and dry as he sat there telling every you all those incoming freshmen that he
was going to develop them and they'd have an NFL fucking career and then all of
a sudden deaths at the back door and he just fucking takes off and goes up to
Seattle.
You know,
I don't think that thing really had anything that tweet had anything to do with
USC.
I think that has to do with his fucking hatred of captain come back there and
the time he ran up the score when he was coaching fucking Syracuse.
Right.
Jim Harbor.
I think it had more to do with that.
Um,
but I was disappointed that the end of his,
his tweet didn't say Hashtag [inaudible]
Woo.
Um,
all right.
Where are we?
How many fucking minutes in our we could I start reading shut.
Jesus.
29,
30 minutes.
30 fucking minutes.
What am I going to do here?
What are we gonna talk about?
The Greenpeace dirty again,
nothing has changed as far as I can tell,
far as I can.
Oh.
Oh one more thing about the fucking football is versus New York football giants.
One again.
And uh,
I don't,
I don't dislike the giants actually love the giants.
Um,
this is a franchise,
right?
Even though they beat the Patriots.
I,
I get,
I get beyond that.
They beat the Patriots.
What the fuck were they supposed to do?
Lose to them?
You know,
they're trying to win the game and they want it good for them.
I don't give a fuck,
but what it is is with every victory they have,
I'm going to have to listen to [inaudible] going on and on and on.
Just fast forward 20 minutes into this podcast,
cause I'm still going to be going on an m.
He still talking about Robinson canal,
like this is what you have to know about Paul Versey.
He likes gummy bears.
He likes going to the movies and he spends 100% of his time when he's talking
about sports,
talking about the 10% of the time that he was actually right,
and it drives me up the fucking wall.
You don't,
one of his predictions was was the Patriots were crazy not to resign.
Matt Cassel.
Okay,
I fucking nailed that one.
I've already talked,
I've talked about this one a million times.
I would give up.
I give up with this guy.
I called the fucking super bowl this year and I put my money down.
I never brought it up to him.
He's already talking about it.
He's already sending me text messages.
This is what kills me.
Like when I call something,
I'm like,
all right.
I got lucky.
Versie actually thinks that something like paranormal happened that he has like
ESP liquid.
He caught when he calls something,
he's got distinct where he kind of puts his head down.
He's like looking through his eyebrows,
yet he gets it.
He gets a little crazy.
That guy is not all there.
Don't buy into his little fucking,
you know,
when you,
when you get the Paul Versey brochure in the mail,
what?
He's coming to your town.
I'm telling you that guy.
He's not all there.
I'm just fucking with you.
I love the guy.
You know what?
This is why I love Paul.
Versey all right.
This is a zillion reasons,
but I have to get back to him.
I had a quick phone call and I was going,
I forget what the fuck I was doing.
I was,
I think it was going in and I'm just going to do a show and he called me up to
talk to me about a veal chop.
He just ate.
You know,
it's just fucking hilarious how much she's into food.
It's ridiculous.
Oh,
this week everybody,
I got a couple of all things comedy.
Um,
our wonderful new podcast network,
um,
that I have to tell you about,
uh,
me and Al Madrigal,
the daily show's in minivan men podcast.
Al Madrigal are going to be hosting a garage,
shale,
a garage sale.
Uh,
both of us are taking shit out of our garages in our lives,
their lives.
I can't even talk.
We're taking stuff on our garages and our lives,
comedy memorabilia,
old hockey sticks.
I got one of those fucking man great systems that they sent me.
They already gave me one.
You know,
what am I supposed to stack two on top of each other?
I don't even think the meat would cook at that point.
Those things is so thick.
So I got one of those.
Uh,
what else do I got?
I got,
uh,
I got some fucking old,
why do I do this?
Let it go.
Uh,
DVDs at all.
Be autographed.
I got this fucking trunk metal locker trunk thing that the last people owned my
house left in the garage.
You know,
I don't know what else bring in,
but,
uh,
you know,
I'm sure he's got a bunch of stuff too.
And,
uh,
all of the proceeds are going to go towards the wounded warrior project.
Um,
also,
uh,
there's another all things comedy show down at Largo here in Los Angeles.
Donald Laci,
Annika just north of Beverly.
I'm going to be eight o'clock this Wednesday.
I will be performing there as well as a bunch of other hosts of podcasts on our
network.
Please come down,
have a good time,
learn about our network.
And uh,
what else?
Um,
all also,
I got to give a shout out to the cage.
Really Awesome podcast hosted by Kevin Christie in Nicu Sef two phenomenal
younger comics.
They young to me.
All right.
They're probably young to you.
But,
uh,
and also if you think I love dogs,
you've got to listen to Kevin Christie.
Dude,
that guy is like,
I'm swear to God.
I think if you pet his dog in the wrong direction,
like a cat,
uh,
you'd probably be missing a limb and he would never apologize and that's why I
love it.
But anyways,
they gave me a nice shout out,
um,
Dad Max Greenfield on their podcasts from the new girl.
And I guess he talked about,
um,
that episode I did where he's basically sticking his head in a coffin with a
dead body there.
And I'm trying to get them to stop doing it because I'm trying to take a gold
chain off the dead.
Dead Party was fucking hilarious.
We,
I think we shot it at one in the morning and he had me laugh in my,
I had such a great time doing that show between working with Max and,
uh,
working with Nick Kroll and all my scenes,
I swear to God,
it seemed like they were one in the morning and I was feeling like I was gonna
pass out and that I can't hack it as an actor in both of them had me laughing my
ass off at one in the morning,
standup comic who doesn't laugh at Shit.
So,
uh,
anyways,
so check out the occasionally awesome podcasts on the all things comedy network.
And there you go.
There's a little mini commercial there.
Let me go back to the,
uh,
go back to a rambling here.
So basically because I don't want to listen to Versie,
you know,
and he's one dump fucking prediction.
His dope.
I think this is the only thing that he's actually going to get right this year.
And we're in November.
As far as I know.
I don't know anything else he said write this year.
He was wrong about the super bowl.
He was wrong about that Christmas sweater that he wore the last time we worked
together.
This is going to be the first.
Ah,
you know what?
Everybody's right.
Every,
every once in a while,
Jesus,
he's going to to eyecare and fuck a 2016.
I'm still gonna be hearing about this.
Yeah.
What about dead fucking judge prediction?
You know?
Um,
so he's actually made me like an eagles fan.
Like I'm rooting for the fucking,
I'm rooting for somebody in that Goddamn division to actually win some fucking
games.
Okay.
Philadelphia Eagles,
Dallas cowboys,
fucking red skins.
I'm done with you.
All right?
But it's not too late.
All three of you,
the giant spotted you.
Six fucking games.
All right.
This is,
this is inexcusable for you to let those kids come back and win the fucking
division.
Absolutely.
Fucking inexcusable.
Then.
I can't say I loved the job.
I actually like the fucking giants.
I just don't want to listen to Versie for the love of God.
Philadelphia Eagles,
Dallas cowboys.
Next week when you play the fucking giants,
could you play full four quarters?
You know,
don't do it for yourselves.
Do it for me.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
He is going to go on for fucking ever.
Um,
all right,
let's read some shit here.
A dollar shave club.
Correction.
This is from a listener.
Hey Bill,
can you change that copy to read rusty soup can instead of rusty soda can
aluminum,
soda cans don't rust.
But the 10 coded soup cans sure as hell will.
I honestly wanted to be helpful.
I can try to break your balls another time.
Thanks for the podcast.
That's fucking hilarious.
Is there any ta,
is there anything better when somebody just like scientifically correct?
You know,
I didn't know that a little bit in cans don't rust.
I had no idea.
I didn't even know the cans are made out of aluminum.
Yeah,
I didn't know what it was.
I thought it was some sort of,
you know,
some sort of metal,
plastic kind of shit.
I had no added on.
It was,
I never knew what it was.
All right.
How to handle conspiracy theories.
Billy bag buster.
Oh,
by the fucking way.
Wait a second.
Wait a minute.
I forgot to bring this up.
Do you guys know that one of my fantasies is coming true this week?
No,
not reading copy correctly.
Uh,
there's two bankers being put to death and Vietnam.
Let me look this up here.
Death v it,
um,
[inaudible] bankers sentenced to death for fraud.
Here we go.
This is what this is what should have been happening in this country in 2008,
like,
okay.
It already should have like,
they should have been at least a hundred bankers dead.
You know what you should do is like smothering them with cash.
No,
what you do is you tie him to the mast of their yacht or this sail boat,
right?
And then you put a bunch of cash at their feet,
all the cash that they stole.
You just light it on fire,
right?
Like Jonah,
fuck it up.
Uh,
let me see if I could find where the fuck is it.
There we go.
Yahoo Free News.
Let's go here.
A Vietnamese former banker and his business associates at been sentenced to
death for their part in the embezzlement of $25 million.
State media has reported 25 million bucks and you get the Goddamn death
sentence.
All right.
So I figured that the people at Aig,
they ought to have like what happened to William Wallace at the end of
Braveheart,
whatever that fucking thing is.
Well they just pull out your fucking end trails like machete.
The pair were among 11 defendants in the nine day trial and Holcim in city state
media reported on Saturday in a case that is heightened Vietnam's effort to show
it is stamping out corruption in the face of widespread public anger over the
issue.
That's the only part of the story.
I don't like the fact that they're trying to make an example.
So I think that they just got a couple of Ollie north here.
They're going to kill two people or 11 it'd be like,
see,
you were doing something and then it goes right back.
Now I don't know what politicians make it Vietnam,
but if it's anything like over here,
you know the bankers put them in office.
So I have no fucking idea.
But anyways,
this is the deal.
Wgu Kwok how 58 the one time chief of the finance subsidiary subsidiary of the
state owned Vietnam Agribank and building from boss Dag van high 56 were
sentenced to death on Friday.
According to state television,
they were given the sentence for embezzlement of assets,
mismanagement,
abusive power and fraud causing serious consequences to the state.
Sound familiar,
everybody?
I just did that.
What I hated last week.
Sound familiar?
Uh,
the other nine defendants were jailed for up to 14 years for violating state
economic regulations.
The report out of the group was accused of embezzling more than $25 million of
state money between April,
2008 and March,
2009 by falsifying financial leasing contracts to reports and state media.
Vietnam is rated one of the world's most corrupt nations.
And graft is a top concern for many ordinary people.
The communist government has vowed to clamp down on the issue.
They will be strict punishment for state.
Uh,
I'm not gonna read the rest of this shit of spare you guys.
I read it pretty well up to that point.
Um,
so there you go.
There you go.
See that doesn't matter what kind of government you have a democracy,
communism,
socialism,
dictatorship.
The fucking bankers are running shit and they need to be put down and the
fucking straight and replaced with honest people.
You know,
like some of those fine folks that I met out there in the heartland.
Oh,
it'd be great.
I would actually go to the execution.
Okay.
Is fucking morbid.
Is that is,
you know.
Okay.
I would actually go there.
Who the fuck is sitting there texting me now?
Yeah.
All right.
Let's go back to the,
uh,
when I just dropped my voice.
Let's go back to the questions for this week.
How to handle conspiracy theories.
Billy Bank,
buster,
I'm all in when it comes to reading and researching ideas,
independent of those we hear all day in the media,
whether it be the banks,
the lizard people,
or the fact that we live in a simulation.
It's all important information.
I'm with you when it comes to shrugging off a particular air of pretentiousness
like that guy in the human farming video.
The problem with general reaction to new information is that everyone does that.
I'm a democrat.
I'm a Republican.
Bullshit where they just pick a side and defend it to death.
Here's the troth all in capital letters.
The truth is,
is that there's some truth to the fact that we are being pushed around by those
in power.
Who the fuck are you to say that this is the truth?
Why can't you just say,
this is your version of the truth?
He came at me all diplomatic.
I was really liking who you are and then all of a sudden you yelled at me.
I don't know where you'll love me in.
I was right there.
Pop it up.
Dube Zip Addepar de [inaudible].
Here's the truth.
The truth is that there is some truth to the fact that we'd been pushed around
by those in power.
It's true that people in power have bigger plans that we,
that we know about.
We know this because it's been that way forever.
It takes,
the current population is so long to get over their emotional reaction to
finding out negative things that by the time they understand everything,
they're dead and the kids are voting for the next jackass.
I agree with the way you handle this stuff.
You're in,
but you're not letting it ruin your life.
This is a revolution of knowledge that can't be stopped.
Now.
Please run for office and stay out of convertibles.
Uh,
all right.
I'm such a defensive asshole.
I thought you were disagreeing with me until right in the end.
Uh,
no,
there's no fucking way.
I'm too God damn dumb and I have jerked off to too much fucking horrific shit on
the,
and uh,
I,
you know,
let doesn't mean that I couldn't be an office.
I would just have to be a company player.
You know,
I really got to start reading up on this fucking guy up in Toronto,
man,
this crack smoking,
pussy ate and fucking mayor,
whoever they got up there.
Okay.
Somebody was,
somebody was trying to tell me,
uh,
literally looking at Toronto Mayor Eating Pussy.
Rob Ford's denies eating Pussy Video.
Okay?
He denies that he ate this woman's Pussy,
said he,
he's married and has plenty to eat at home
and then walked off.
You know,
like he just dropped the mic.
That's the greatest fucking thing ever.
You gotta love that kind of honesty.
What the fuck is this?
Is this somebody piggyback?
I don't want this thing.
Uh,
Jesus.
Is this a commercial I have to sit through?
I just hit mute.
All right,
here we go.
Blasting was Olivia gone back?
I wanted to eat her pussy.
He found out I've never said that in my life.
I would never do that.
I'm happy married.
I've got more than enough to eat at home,
dude.
Did he just have a fucking Jersey with his name on it and the back?
This guy is the fucking greatest thing ever.
Hang on.
Wait a minute that there's a flabbergasted lady.
You Go.
All right.
I know we're applying right now.
Speaking as me report does.
You know what?
I Dunno if he was born that way or smoking crack gives you some balls lead.
This guy just doesn't give a fuck.
I don't know anything about this story.
It's only what I've heard.
I don't know if you're,
if you're in office for life,
but
if he smokes crack the way I drink booze,
I don't think it's going to affect his job.
You know?
If he just has a couple,
two or three cracks,
the end of the day.
You like smoking crack.
Yeah,
that's,
you know something.
There's just something you got to go down swinging in life.
Right.
That's the way to go down because he knows eventually it's like if I'm going to
get squeezed out,
fucking do.
The guy had a jersey with his name on it with a number on the back.
I don't know what the fuck that was about,
but um,
okay.
Whatever.
He's owned by the banks too,
if you might as well have somebody entertaining.
Isn't that right Cleo?
Oh,
cleo.
All you were sleeping.
I'm sorry buddy.
How are you doing?
The fucking dog is hilarious.
I came over,
had an early flight,
right.
And I come home right and I pull up to the house or whatever and I come in and
she didn't know was coming home.
Now she has no,
I have no income and home.
She has no concept of me leaving.
I just walk out the door and she hasn't like she hasn't,
I'll go to Wichita.
Kind of a fucking stupid sentence.
Was that,
oh,
it was to what you were thinking bill?
Um,
so I walk in and she hates hardwood floors.
She just feels like she can't get any sort of balance on them,
so she has to walk really slow with their head down.
So I come in and she hears that the door unlocking.
So she comes running out and she knows it's me and she's all excited,
but she's walking on hardwood floors.
So she was walking really slowly while her tail was wagging 90 miles an hour and
a fucking shaking or pit bull booty like walking sideways.
It's one of the best laughs if you don't have a dog,
you're a fucking asshole.
What does a cat do?
Well maybe cat does something cause I have never,
I didn't grow up with cats.
What does a cat do that is like similar to that?
I remember I dated this girl and she had a cat.
She had a cool one and I would fucking wake up in the morning.
This thing would be standing on my chest like doing that thing,
you know where they're sorta like,
like to try to pull your shirt apart.
I used to make me laugh,
but uh,
I just don't like that.
They shit inside.
Okay.
It goes to the Goddamn box.
Smells like,
I don't know,
there's just no appreciation from,
maybe I'm too needy to be a cat owner.
I respect cat.
So you know,
they're in the deal but not have it.
And they also retain their hunting skills.
They keep those polished.
I think that they know that the dollar's going to crash the way they always go
out and fucking kill my cis stuff.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Where is it here advice?
My mom thinks she's a psychic.
Uh,
hey,
big red,
long time fan and loyal follower of the [inaudible] podcast for the past five
years.
Can't wait for the new podcast tee shirts.
I'm picking him up today.
Oh,
was it a journey with this fucking company?
Jesus Christ.
It took forever.
Forever.
For fucking ever.
We changed the design a couple of times and then,
you know,
and then from then on,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
I need your advice on how to bring my 58 year old mob back to reality.
Ever since my mom's menopause,
my brother and I came to the realization that my mom believes she has the
ability to speak and see those who have,
who have crossed over to the other side.
This has to do with her menopause?
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't think,
uh,
I think you look at it the wrong answer.
Uh,
she even has no problems pushing her beliefs on to complete strangers.
For example,
um,
I was having a stressful time during my career by mom proceeds to pull out these
two and 10 and like rod shaped like the letter l while holding the short end of
the Rod.
She proceeds to walk up to meet
and the two meet in the rods,
m e t
the rods move closer together in her hands.
She says I am surrounded by negative activity.
Okay.
Wait a minute.
What kind of witchcraft,
what we talk while holding the short end of the Rod,
she proceeds to walk up
to meet me I think is what you went to say and the rods move closer together in
a hands.
I linked chicks just guessed that she says I'm surrounded by negative activity.
She then proceeds to make me think of the most positive thoughts I can envision
such as the birth.
What the fuck dude,
you got to finish your sentences.
Birth of your son,
I guess is what that means.
She then steps back and then while I love,
I use the word home correctly,
I'm assuming and then you can't get this other shit.
Right.
She then steps back and then while I'm sup supposedly thinking positive
thoughts,
she walks backwards toward me and the rod slowly separate apart.
She comments that the spirits are now in my favor like an asshole.
I thought of the most depressing thoughts I could just to prove that she was
moving the damn rods herself.
After pouring it out,
my mom freaks out and breaks out crying and yelling,
saying how much of a jerk I am that I would,
that I should respect her abilities and they aren't to be toyed with
Jesus Christ.
She sounds like she's going to stab you with a butter knife.
Okay.
You know what I just thought of?
I just thought of misery.
Like you're going to wake up tied to the bed and she's going to be standing
there with fucking lightning going off in the background.
What a fucking you mobs?
A jerk dote.
Okay.
You're busted her for lying and then she uses the age old fucking woman,
um,
manipulating technique of crying.
Right.
He should have held it to it.
It's like you're,
you're yelling at me cause you're lying.
You lied to me,
mom.
How could you do that?
Put the fucking TV antenna down.
All right.
Yeah.
Sit down and have a fucking sandwich.
What's wrong with you?
He says,
I love my mom bill and I just want her to come to her senses.
Obviously jokes don't help to persuade her that she isn't Nostradamus any advice
you are Nia might have would be appreciated.
Maybe it's just me,
but this whole spiritualism shit feels like a fad.
Just like the show long island medium.
I don't know that show.
Ah,
yeah.
I don't know what to to,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Is Ti,
does she have a job?
Okay.
Is she sick of her career and she's trying to go the Tarot card reading thing?
I have no idea.
Don't know what to say
to you there.
I bet.
I mean,
I would give her shit like,
mom,
you lied to me.
Okay.
All right.
You're sitting there saying that,
uh,
you're,
you're like,
you're healing me and you're not.
Yeah.
I don't know when somebody goes crazy,
dude,
I don't know.
I don't know what to tell.
You either got to roll with it or you got to,
I would want to bring it to a doctor cause God knows they're going to put her
all of the latest drugs and use her as a fucking Guinea pig.
So I might try to avoid that.
I Dunno dude.
I feel like I'm letting you down here,
but I'd rather not give you any advice because I don't have any,
rather than give you some bad advice.
Yeah.
Oh,
free sat.
I love my mom.
I need advice.
You might.
How to make it come to our senses.
Uh,
I dunno.
Why don't you go buy a magic kit and get better at it than she is
and then somehow try to turn her into your student and it just one day,
just say that she failed.
You know that she needs to go back to beat him up.
Okay.
Just grow out a long beard and start wearing all white and sick fucking Indian
style.
The Lotus position,
I believe it's called.
And uh,
you know,
like candles and stuff that'll give you credibility with her and just tell her
that she's a,
you know,
she's not good at it now.
They still make her cry again.
I Dunno,
no disrespect to Meryl Streep,
but they can all do it on command,
you know,
I'm not saying she's not a good actress and doesn't deserve those fucking shiny
trophies,
but I don't know what to tell you.
They just can do it at the drop of a fucking hat.
She's sitting there with two TV and tennis and the guy borrowed son buster for
lying and immediately could,
she can start crying.
There's not a guy in the world that could fucking pull that emotion out of their
ass like that.
Or are they a menopause Twat?
Good lab.
Sorry.
Now just talk bad about your mom.
Her,
uh,
postmenopause vagina.
Okay,
let's,
do you know what?
I think that's a nice segue into this next,
uh,
advertisement,
trying to beat two strokes,
people stamps.com
but the holiday almost here,
you don't have time to go to the post office traffic parking.
It will be packed with everybody mailing their holiday gifts in packages.
So do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can avoid all the hassle,
man.
Uh,
go to the post office during the busy holiday season.
Everything you would do at the post office,
you can do right at your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer,
print postage for any letter or package the inches instinct you need it.
Then the mailman picks it up.
So easy and convenient.
I use stamps.com to set out all my DVDs,
all of my posters by t shirts,
whatever,
upselling that week.
I've a moron if I can figure out how to do it.
So can you right now get this special offer when you use my last name?
[inaudible] B U R R for a no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital
scale and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter bur
bur are,
was that one under,
what was it?
Two was ever a hiccup in there?
I don't think so.
Uh,
he voice the holidays are coming and as a business owner,
you know what that means?
Crickets.
Okay.
I don't get that.
Face it the next couple of months or the cub.
Oh,
I get it now we read this again.
He voiced the holidays are coming of Jesus Christ.
Take three,
take three.
Let me get some water here.
Oh God,
that's good.
He voiced the holidays are coming and as a business owner,
you know what that means?
Crickets face it.
The next couple of months of the calm before the storm.
Now's the time to do something that will dramatically help your 2014 he voice.
He voices the simple technology that helps you to make more money,
uh,
with he voice toll free or local numbers.
Call routing tools at a professional dial by name directory.
Your business will look like a million bucks we had with the voice if you can.
If you can't take a call,
they will transcribe the voicemail and email it to you.
You'll never be caught off guard again.
He voice has saving,
has been saving companies thousands of dollars every month,
making them more efficient and more productive.
There's no quicker,
easy way to transfer your business,
transform your business for 2014 and with the voice you can,
I'm just gonna throw my bag of clubs right in the water and with the voice.
You can try it before you buy it right now.
Do you can get a 30 day trial to eve voice when you go to [inaudible] dot com
slash burr or go to [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner.
That's the voice.com/billboard bill barr or billboard.com and click on the eve
voice banner.
Now's the time to shake.
Take charge of your business.
They prepare for a productive 2014 go to [inaudible] dot com slash bill burr or
go to [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner for your Free 30 Day
trial.
That's a voice.com/built [inaudible] dot com and click on the voice banner,
Jesus fucking Christ.
How many times I've got to try to say my name,
uh,
concern.
Brother.
Hey,
bill loved the show.
Well thank you.
He says,
I got a situation I could use some advice.
My sister is 16 years old and dating a 22 year old.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
I got it.
Fights.
Go out to the goddamn garage and get a fucking shovel.
Dig the hole first.
Ah,
don't do that.
I'm not advocating murder.
Just bury them alive for a few minutes.
Uh,
they met at a church function.
Oh,
for fuck's sakes,
dude,
this is making me upset.
My sister is 16 years old,
16 years old and she's dating a 22 year old.
They met at a church function over a year ago and even though he lives two
states away,
they've been keeping in contact.
What the fuck,
dude?
How many more sexual Predator red flags do you need?
He goes,
I just found out my parents have invited him to Thanksgiving this year.
Do you live in like the Middle East or something?
Is this some sort of custom that is widely accepted in some far away land?
My initial reaction is to beat the shit out of this fucker creep.
Oh,
beat the shit out of this fucking creep.
Sorry.
I don't think that that will solve anything in the long run,
so I'm trying to keep a level head and be mature about this,
but to be honest with you,
I haven't got a fucking clue as to what to do.
My parents are obviously mentally unstable and I'm not equipped to talk sense
into a 16 year old girl said,
if you could tell me what to say to this guy to make him understand in a
nonviolent way that this is wrong and needs to stop,
I'd appreciate it.
See Dude,
you're going on the same journey I,
I started,
you found out immediately.
I'm thinking of getting a shovel and I'm burying this fucking guy in the ground.
But you know,
as I know,
violence is not the way he goes.
The scariest thing about this is that in this weird ass church,
my family belongs to several of my sister's friends have gotten married at 17
and 18 and that just can't happen here.
I know this is a fucked up situation,
but I be grateful for any help you,
you have to offer.
Thank you.
And Go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
I would look up some stuff about cults.
I would get some professional help on this one.
Dude.
You know,
people ask me advice on this and you know,
it's usually much lighter than this,
but dude,
you're talking about,
God forbid if this guys hooking up with her,
you get,
you literally have a sex offender on your hands here.
Can you get the local authorities involved?
Can you call the cops?
I mean,
I,
I don't know.
I have no idea what to do.
I'm afraid if you do something like that,
it's going to make her run into his arms even further.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't know what to do because you can't get violent with the guy.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
And I don't know if you're making a joke about your parents being mentally
unstable.
Dude.
This is like some doctor drew shit calling doctor drew.
If you're going to go the show business route.
All right.
Cause he's actually a professional.
I'm a fucking idiot.
So I don't listen to me,
but I would try to get some professional help and with every fiber in my being,
I hope that you fucking solve this problem because that guy,
that guy should be living in a fucking dumpster.
The fuck kind of a quota.
You're 20 toe,
you know,
that's one of those guys.
What?
He's fucking 32 he's still going to be going to have to 16 olds.
I fucking guarantee it.
That's just fight.
That is fucking creepy.
The difference in age between 16 and 22 was a fucking lifetime.
That's disgusting.
Uh,
I dunno sir.
I would get professional help.
I'm sorry.
There's nothing fucking funny about that at all.
Um,
all right.
From a young lady.
Oh,
this is great.
A woman writing it.
I've been trying to get women to write in,
but you know,
they probably shut off my podcast because they're decent human beings from a
younger lady.
A dear bill.
I have a 16 year old off fuck.
We're back to 16 year old women.
Gelly guess you're dating this 22 year old guy and you're fucking,
your older brother's getting into the way the relationship.
Okay.
All right.
I'm 60.
I have a 16 year old lady who loves stand up comedy and it's my dream to do
headlining stand up when I grow up.
Currently I've taking stand up classes with blah blah,
blah.
Not going to say who you have to get the place in this city and this other city.
Someday I want to open for you,
but I want some advice at a favor.
A favor.
Oh g.
Um,
I know that it will take a while for me to be amazing at stand up.
So what should I do when I bomb on stage?
Do I just keep bobbing?
I've only done one standup show,
but I surprisingly did well.
Oh,
good for you.
You did better than I did.
Not only did okay.
Uh,
what should I do after high school?
I want to move to La and just to open Mike and take classes.
It will be hard though,
since I'm not 21,
I have to wait outside the clubs,
which is so annoying.
But if you have a better idea,
please tell me,
uh,
because you know what you're talking about.
Lastly,
the favor,
it would be amazing if you did an all ages show in Los Angeles to San Diego.
Thank you for your time.
Uh,
just so you know,
you're the reason I want to do stand up because you're freaking hilarious.
That's,
that's great.
All right,
well,
first of all,
you're way ahead of the game.
You're only 16 years old.
I didn't start until I was almost 24.
Okay.
Um,
as far as moving to la,
I would not do that.
I would move to a town.
I would probably more if I was you,
I haven't moved La,
maybe San Francisco.
Uh,
I would move to a city that has a good comedy scene where you can develop and
learn how to be a comedian and get some momentum going before you try and start
in La.
La is the hardest place as far as I can tell in America to start doing stand up
comedy because you have all these professional comics who now feel they're ready
to take a shot moving to la and they're all getting on stage and that they're
having problems trying to get on stage or at least I did back in the day.
And um,
okay.
So I would give yourself time to develop and um,
all right,
what else did you yes.
Okay.
Uh,
okay.
What did you say?
You said how did it,
what are you doing?
You're bombing.
Um,
bobbing is just,
that's just a part of it.
Uh,
so what'd you say?
What should you do if you start bombing on stage?
Ah,
I duNno.
Make Fun of the joke that you just told it didn't work.
Make Fun of yourself.
You just got to stand there and take it and you'll figure out your own way how
to get through it.
But when you,
Bob,
don't get down on yourself because it happens to everybody.
I've been working on a bit this whole weekend.
It's been,
I been eating my balls on it every fucking night and it's pissing me off because
I know it's funny.
I just don't know how to make it funny yet.
So that part of it never ends.
Uh,
what else did you say?
Which I do have to highschool.
Don't move to La.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't advise that.
I would not advise that.
I would advise my already said what to do.
Uh,
okay.
Decided other than that,
just fucking write shit that you think's funny.
Don't hang out with negative people that bring it down.
Don't hang out with other comics who are weirdly competing with you and happy
slash resenting your success.
You know,
get rid of those fucking people.
Paying around positive motivated people.
And then you guys,
you could create your own shit.
Start filming it and then you come here and you stormed the castle and you'll be
the new wave and I'll be wanting to get into your movie.
So be on your TV shelf.
All right,
so good luck to you.
I think that's awesome that you're doing or the 16 you've got more courage than
I ever had.
All right.
Here we go.
Trying to stop masturbating.
Well,
you're talking to the wrong person.
Yeah.
Oh,
talking to you about stop masturbating.
You might as well talk to Colonel Sanders about stop frying chicken.
Huh?
Taking the edge off Bill Buford Open.
You get the drover referenced?
Of course I do.
Uh,
or is it Beauford that was never like it was the play for,
yes,
he played for one of those prog bands of the 70s Denise,
I have no idea.
A big fan of your work.
And I thought Bill Buford.
Right.
Okay.
I used to get him and Alan White confused.
I don't know why.
Big Fan of your work,
and I thought I'd get your input on this.
I'm trying to stop jerking off.
I'm not afraid of going blind or getting hairy palms or any of that shit.
I've even read that there are health benefits to masturbating by my primary
concern.
Is that a beginning to develop premature ejaculation?
I've never heard of that.
Not Premature ejaculation,
but by jerking off that your
well maybe a know yourself too well
right there.
Boom.
Right there.
You just fucking all it's over.
Uh,
I also can't help it feel disgusted whenever I bust went off.
Call it Catholic guilt.
Yeah,
it is Catholic guilt.
Um,
I don't masturbate on an insane basis only once every two or three days.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you know,
you like a fucking DH
in my world.
Uh,
fuck a relief pitcher.
but it's the only sexual activity I'm getting at the moment and I can't go more
than around nine days without an intense urge to do it through.
This is really getting too personal for me.
I have a small Dick and I'm fine with that.
Learning to accept it.
My Dick has below is below average in length has freed me from my penis envy and
it was a disproportionately large weight off my chest.
It's the sexual equivalent to the last rap battle in eight mile.
You can't tell me Shit I don't already know.
But having a small Dick and being a minute man is more than I can take.
Yeah.
You don't want the Combo platter there.
Uh,
I know that you've advised people to rub one off,
rub one out on a different occasion than I respect that because things
definitely come into perspective after you finished Mass Bay.
But can you suggest any method for people who are trying to hold back on choking
the chicken?
Thanks in advance and go fuck yourself now.
I can't.
I can't,
I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
You know,
I think of most dictators in the world would fucking rub one out or get a
goddamn handy from some fucking chick dress like a nurse.
I don't think there'd be any war until like two in the afternoon.
Uh,
I dunno.
I,
you definitely don't want to just be doing that to yourself.
You want to be in some sort of a fucking relationship,
uh,
you're fine with having a small deck as far as that goes a year.
I would definitely go downtown first.
Make sure you know she's one up on you and then fucking have at it.
But you didn't ask me about that,
so I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm throwing this one to Dr. Draw again,
trying to hold back,
choke with,
I don't think,
say run with it.
This is the premature ejaculation thing I think might be a problem.
Yeah,
it is a problem.
You said you don't want that.
So I would consult a,
uh,
you guys,
you guys are really hit me with some heavy ones this week.
You know,
I don't know what to tell you do I would I would contact a
therapist,
sex therapist or some shit?
MMM.
Let's see.
What the fuck would I do if I was premature ejaculating?
Uh,
I would rub two out
and then I take my exhausted dick out and then I would see,
I have a go then see how that happened.
That's all I got.
Right.
That's what you get when you listen to a free podcasts.
That's the kind of advice you get.
MMM,
yeah,
I would,
I would go to a professional.
All right.
There we go.
Wow.
Those last two were brutal.
Oh,
the last two audit three,
except for the,
uh,
the standup comedian one was awesome.
That was a nice reprieve.
Um,
anyway,
so that's the podcast for this week.
I will be tweeting and,
uh,
all the final details about the garage sale,
the all things comedy garage sale,
and um,
he can call us up bid on some stuff.
It helps the wounded warriors project all of us to do a quick spot at the laugh
factory,
uh,
for Rob Schneider show.
Uh,
all the proceeds will be benefiting,
um,
all the victims and the survivors,
I guess I should say of a typhoon out there in the Philippines.
Um,
and that's it.
That's my week.
I got to,
I think I got a Gig in new haven this weekend and I'm going to the Harvard Yale
game of fucking awesome is that I'll be probably sitting amongst at least the
next three presidents when I go to that game.
I'm really looking forward to it stuff.
One of the first bowls,
I think it is the first bowl that was built in this country as far as stadiums.
Uh,
so really excited to see a game there.
I'll be there with dude.
I called it Paul Versey and I'm actually going to bet the cowboys with them next
week just to make this fun,
this whole bet,
him calling it all right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.